a study that they did in Switzerland
this is absolutely true found out that
bearded men on average have more germs
than most dogs real story there it is
men with beards have more germs than
dogs apparently human beards are often
filled with bacteria now I'm of course
very concerned because we often have
bearded men sitting in our audience and
because I want to keep everyone healthy
I'm initiating a new safety protocol to
eliminate any beard borne bacteria I'm
doing this for safety Billy could you
send in the beard extraction unit please
great areas there yeah that's fine
justify there's a guy right there
great come on Conan come on get here
come on let you go take your dirty beard
with you
okay and bring in the replacement oh
that's a good boy there you go all right
very nice there's his replacement now he
looks like a real fan of the show - oh
okay more interested in her one of our
cameramen Teddy sorry Teddy that's a
pretty big beard you're gonna have to go
as well sorry you got to go out you go
alright let's bring in his replacement
let's get in Teddy's replacement right
now
okay we're uh Conan peak we're and we're
pretty much set here what spot Mandy I I
see you know another one of those gross
beard guys out there right now okay
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he was doing so good we we've rehearsed
this nine times and he kept the beard on
each time and he knew we were doing it
live and that dog was like getting that
dog for a minute and look at his face
you can tell he's just what are you
yelling at me for you're the one that
bailed on the sketch and he's yelling at
me he's saying it's humiliating he's
saying it's he's saying what I'm doing
for living humiliating all right let's
this this fun dog over here mister
chuckles yes I'm looking at you why
don't you uh that's how people looked at
me the first three years I was on the
air
[Laughter]
yeah give me a favor sir would you like
a sort of commercial do us a favor
enthrone a commercial there you go yes
Jon rudnitsky air
[Applause]